hi everyone this is Jerry this is a live
blitz game five minute game okay this is
a game against a Chester boy let's try
e4 typically I'm a d4 player but let's
see what we got
it's a ceiling defense Knight f3 very
common move and I guess we'll go for an
open Sicilian d4 just change on d4
Knight f6 you might see a dragon Knight
c3 g6 let's go with Knight c3 so g6 a
lot of a lot of possibilities from this
pointer here alright so a six the night
off
let's try s Bishop e3 Bishop e3 e5
Knight b3 might be three and let's see
what I want to do with this guy here so
that's shirt
I played Queen here and or on here and
maybe a bishop here let's just go with
this right here Queen d2 Castle
queenside so this is a very theoretical
opening right here for sure
since this pawn is backward you're gonna
see a lot of the black pieces focusing
on this square right here d5 since it's
a square that can't be protected by any
of the black pieces so Queen c7 I'm not
so sure I'm used to seeing that and in
fact I'm not really used to seeing the
light side of the Sicilian here very
often at all so what to do f4 trying to
open up open up the position f4 maybe f5
seems reasonable let's try that
f4 possibly pressing f5 and then maybe
g4 g5 stuff okay I think I might be
going for that let's try this so I'm
going to try a little pawn storm here g4
g 4g 5 it seems reasonable let's go for
it
in fact I'm welcoming this sort of
exchange of bishops because that will
make my control over this light square
that much better you know for as long as
this bishop stays here it's controlling
this Square and this bishop here isn't
controlling this square here so the
exchange of these two would increase my
control over d5 so I'm already getting
ready to just flush this night away
five plot my knight here hit the Queen
hit the bishop and his King looks like
it's gonna be cooked very soon actually
so let's see let's try g5 push them away
that seems reasonable I have to watch
out for this pawn you know since this
battery is coming down against my king
but take stakes if the knight takes here
my knight is on it so I guess we could
just do Bishop takes Bishop here
followed by Knight here hitting the
bishop or maybe just press here to smash
up in his Kings side this is gonna be an
annoying move not sure whether or not to
do it yet on here would really just
create serious holes and also just the
opening of files the F file but F file
or G file potentially so what am I
contemplating Bishop takes Knight takes
do I really have to think anything
beyond that I don't think so let's try
that
so my knight is here and should be very
annoying in fact I could see just in an
endgame even if I don't have some sort
of an attack I could just see this nice
strength right here being a great asset
so that's why I may be considering Queen
d3 it's hitting this pawn so I really
need to worry about that
how does he really get rid of this
Knight I have night here and the Queen
would take care so let's not do that
what King here came to be one or maybe
just offer Queen trade or maybe push my
pawn here new that's reasonable push my
pawn here but then I give his Knights
this square so I'm gonna try hmm I'm
gonna try an endgame let's go for this
Queen trade and where's where's my
advantage
isin the fact that this Knight is
awesome this bishop is a big dummy so I
have the better Bishop a nice Knight
post and I'll actually wait if he takes
here takes takes with the rook how do I
defend this
alright b5 that seems like it's a good
move I'm gonna I'm gonna get my King
here cuz I want to be able to if he
takes my queen I keeps calling him ahem
I don't know who this is Chester boy I
guess it's a him
Queen takes pawn takes and then I won't
have to worry about defending this pawn
so maybe I could influence this this
capture here
so I guess the other feature King here
was protecting this pawn so this Knight
maneuver is possible this night on b3
usually is the one of the worst minor
pieces on the white side so let's I
guess reposition him so now I'm thinking
more if you're not if you're not going
to trade Queens let's let's just go with
some sort of an attack so I don't want
to move any of these pawns that'll just
speed up the development get rid of this
guy I don't want to have to tolerate
that night so still this guy's a monster
even if he gets taken so push here I
guess I better go for this
let's just open some stuff up maybe
maybe these rooks will be put to some
use less than two minutes so actually
this square is gonna be really bad if he
doesn't take because I could have moved
my knight Queen here to here so I guess
let's get this guy involved Knight here
I probably could even do do with out
guarding this pawn I could probably just
threaten here clean here here or
actually just Queen here to here is
gonna be lights out in fact I think this
is just game over already
Knight here may be actually just Knight
here I could just play Queen here I
guess I could just go for this I don't I
don't see I don't see what he has here
I'm gonna lose this pawn with check but
let's just calculate here so Queen here
what do you do I'm threatening to just
take the night followed by Queen here
Queen h3 Queen takes pawn King here what
do you have now I'm still threatening
that same thing if Knight hear Queen
here checked King in the corner Queen
takes pawn and then I got Queen here
mate I think I'll have to do a rook lift
like rook here I think that's his best
move I think he has to play like Queen
here well he doesn't have to take here
but he probably will and now rook here I
believe is the only move let's see if
I'm right anything else is gonna lose
that's this is gonna lose Knight here
King here Queen takes pawn that's game
over so a little bit of calculation paid
off here
in this night what attributed to this
win is basically this bishop was bad in
this the exchange of those light squares
really enabled my night to just sit on
this d5 Square and cause black a serious
headache so that's it this game alright
so that's all for this video hope you
got something out of it take care bye